the perfect trick shot sometimes so
perfect you wonder if they're even real
that's why for the last three videos
we've been on a quest a quest to
determine whether modern computing power
is more powerful than man himself by
creating real life perfect trick shots
and putting them side by side with the
same shot created entirely with CGI this
time we're pulling out all the stops
with a four game dunk tank trick shot
Gauntlet that will determine the fit of
humanity once and for all with the fate
of humanity be sealed to a Wally future
future Days
or is there still an intangible abiding
hope that lives within the human spirit
for the first game we have behind the
back basketball shot through a mirror
shot number two the Hungry Hungry Hippo
you must make a ping pong bounce off the
Apple box and into the cone that ball
will then travel down said two into said
cup that is spinning furiously on the
wheel of death
one additional challenge is that I will
be shooting left-handed and Jordan will
be clicking his Mouse left hand in the
Wally future neither left no right
matters and the dextrocity shot number
three is the Icarus you must make a ping
pong ball sending it up high until it
bounces off of this from there it
bounces one two three times into your
classic American plastic cup this
wouldn't be a dunk tank trick shot
Gauntlet if the final shot didn't send
your opponent into the dunk tank itself
and we're gonna be bouncing them from
the seated position off of The Little
Tikes trampoline and into the red button
sending your opponents into the dunk
tank once and for all one of us is gonna
get wet and as always if you say dude or
perfect you must make a classic beer
pong shot only this time from the seated
position inside of the dunk you know
Jordan there's something everyone has
been thinking but uh people around here
have been afraid to say
I can't believe you had a shirt made
it's what is true and in the pursuit of
perfection I will be using no wind oh
well for once in a long time we find
ourselves in agreement
trickster's ready ready three
two
one begin
here we go
everything is inverted this is awful
okay so I'm giving myself some velocity
we got it got it I'm not gonna go too
far I know it's behind and down let's
see what happens
[Music]
honestly this mirror is messing me up
to my tool set we're just gonna go 500
our initial shot and we'll play it oh
it's too strong but it's the right path
[Music]
let's go
I'm gonna like develop
er
dang it I can't we just started
oh my God
why do I talk yes come on I'm back in
I'm back in when he does that I start to
I'm like it's like a power play I start
to smell the blood in the water
oh my God all I need to do is pull this
down just a little bit okay
I gotta calm down and just get it
well how's this for blood in the water
we got our first shot baby let's go
that's the real one no wind in baby
that's it all right I'm never looking in
a mirror again all right shot two here
we go oh the ping pong Cinco food tube I
love the shot our Apple box our tube and
our revolving wheel of death what's
great about this obviously it shows you
your vector so you can aim your shots a
lot better than I could in the first one
oh that's in that's it
yeah we anticipated that we anticipated
Jordan are you on the second game second
game you have to be doing the mouse with
your left hand as per the rules oh
dude forgot about that who signed off on
these rules where was I don't miss the
meeting yeah you did dang it I should
have been here this one it's it's all
about finesse okay not only is it
left-handed but it also has to bounce
and then go higher end time up with the
cups you have you have time on this one
you just got to get to it oh my God
what is it oh it's gonna miss oh it's
gonna miss see you can't just focus on
making it you got to make it at the
right time left says right
what is oh my gosh all my shortcuts are
reversed too everything is mirrored hold
on these twists are blowing my mind
right now
I'm a ping pong balls oh come on all
right I need more okay I'm just gonna
have to wing it play way too strong dude
this Vector thing is such a game changer
wait I said when did I say it
why why is this who I am oh
keep it lit okay I know what to do now
though I Gotta Throw it higher
is it
I'm done
let's go three more
oh my gosh we'll go minus five four
point five
it's my right hand so much sorry I'm
sorry I never appreciated you the trick
on this is getting enough height oh
let's see oh it's getting intense up in
here people are really focused they're
both these on the left hand so it looks
like it's hard
the timing honestly the most frustrating
part is just navigating around the scene
that's it that's it
timing is everything Jordan and uh quite
frankly you're late moving on this is
the most challenging ping pong run we've
ever done here on Corridor crew
oh it feels good to be able to use my
right hand again uh oh okay maybe I need
a little more bounce out of the box
oh come on come on come on it's in it's
in the tube enhance
oh that's so close okay I've seen the
timing 36 degrees Revolution every 60
Seconds
I don't know you have to get the first
bounce exactly right
started at frame 50. I don't know yes
play go in go in
that's it yes come on
come on
[Music]
nope I gotta stop paying attention Okay
so let's ride out the gate how how
already okay so if I can get it there
okay now I need some freaking velocity
come on
[Music]
oh this is incredibly difficult and I
have to like keep it from going too far
on the top one
a little bit further give me the bounce
I need
we're on third box we can we can do this
no wins though no wind this is a full
windless Endeavor this would be a career
defining moment what a sad career
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a tiny strike box and I have to
hit it basically in one spot in the
exact spot
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
I gotta keep the pressure on him where
is that going is that traditionally
correct crap we might need to change
something I don't want to change the
trajectory of the shot because that
changes everything
I really don't want to change the
trajectory that's going to jack me out
and I gotta redo everything 0.7
come on
I've got one two two three four five
fifteenth Outlast bounce how's the
trajectory is that trajectory good it's
just your arm gets tired there's no
muscle fatigue in a physics render
oh no
can someone collect my balls
oh wait never mind just kidding don't
need it
this is freaking psycho crystals come on
[Music]
come on dude
dang it I'm too excited
no that was sick starting boom bang bang
in oh my God
fuel me you want some animal crackers
too yeah put the Animal Crackers in the
food tube
golly
tastes really bad yeah I'm sure it is
but it's a future what are you gonna do
you know looks like we're building a
little bit of an audience the crew's now
watching because we're getting to the
final trick shots this is just
insufferable
[Music]
we're done we're done okay
[Applause]
[Music]
final shot come on Final
s
is get the pivot the right direction
this is this is nerve-wracking so the
amount of bounces is crazy here that is
really hard
[Music]
how far do we need to go I haven't got a
shot off
[Music]
we're all tied up once and for all manvi
machine you got the audience here loser
gets wet
oh
that was close no oh my gosh I hate this
the noises
oh that's so close come on
uh 8.6
[Music]
that was way too close way too close for
comfort this is not the future that I
saw for me and for us right it's the
future that I saw pretty you saw for me
but I'm not gonna argue with perfection
you were the better man today man still
has a place as much as it breaks my
heart here's the thing here's the thing
I'll give you
five chances
to knock me
into the dunk tank but you're gonna have
to hold a real ball in your real hands
and you're gonna have to really try to
knock me in there without using a
machine I'm in you're in I'm in I
appreciate it brother you can just start
growing because I'm just gonna keep
going because the thing is when you do
this if you make it you are admitting
your own Humanity
you literally
all Cuts exclusive shows it's so close
all the above um so you know it's pretty
great and uh as well Jordan I mean look
at him if you would have spent more time
out
[Music]
all right Jordan
welcome back brother
welcome back brother Welcome To Earth
welcome to earn